MY FRIENDS THE BROADWAY
PRODUCER, WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO BROADWAY?
WHEN WE COME BACK.
PHYSICAL PHYSICAL >> Tucker:
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," I’M
BRIAN CALLED ME TO.
TUCKER DUBBED HIM THE CREEPY
LAWYER AND RIGHT NOW CPL WILL BE
BUT FIRST, MAJOR SACRIFICES
DURING THE CORONAVIRUS LOCK
STONES.
BUSINESSES BY THE WAY WERE
DESTROYED, UNEMPLOYMENT RECORD
HIGH, STILL HAD 1.3 MILLION
TODAY.
AND NOW AFTER MONTHS OF
RESTRICTIONS, THE VIRUS IS BACK
AND POLITICIANS WANT TO DO THE
EXACT SAME THING AGAIN.
>> SO THE SECTORS THAT WERE
CLOSING STAY WHY DO,
RESTAURANTS, WINERIES, MUSEUMS
AND BARS TO OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE.
NOW WITH COUNTIES ON THE
MONITORING LIST, WE HAVE THIS
LIST.
FITNESS CENTERS, PLACES OF
WORSHIP, OFFICES FOR NONCRITICAL
SECTORS, CRITICAL CARE SERVICES
INCLUDING HAIR SALONS, BARBER
SHOPS AND INDOOR MALLS.
>> Brian: AT THE NEWS IS THEY
HAVE THE FULL SCREEN BUILT
ALREADY FROM A MONTH AGO.
SO WITH SO MUCH SHUTDOWN FATIGUE
WILL PEOPLE ACTUALLY OBEY THE
SECOND WAVE OF SHUTDOWN?
SOME BUSINESS OWNERS LIKE BARBER
SHOP OWNER WANDA MIA’S DIDN’T
WANT TO DEBATE THE FIRST WAVE.
>> I READ SOMETHING WHERE MY
PRODUCER SAID I DON’T CARE IF I
GET IT, MEANING COVID-19.
DO YOU STILL FEEL THAT WAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
A LOT OF US ARE GOING TO GET IT.
MOST LIKELY WE ARE NOT GOING TO
DIE, WE HAVE 99-POINT SOMETHING
PERCENT OF LIVING IF WE CONTRACT
IT OR NOT.
>> HANG ON, JUAN.
LET ME JUMP IN.
NEITHER OF US ARE DOCTORS, THERE
ARE NUMBERS BEING THROWN OUT.
I’VE HAD IT AND IT WAS NOT FUN.
>> Brian: THAT’S EASY, ONE OF
THEM IS STILL GETTING PAID.
WE SAW THAT INTERVIEW AND WE’VE
INVITED HIM WANT TO DEFEND HIS
POSITION >> THE COPS CAME IN
HERE TODAY AND TO GIVE US A
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER FROM THE
CITY.
>> Brian: ARE YOU GOING TO
ABIDE BY IT?
>> DEFINITELY I’M NOT.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AND STAY
OPEN, MY BARBERS WILL CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY.
DO I EXPECT THEM TO COME AND
DISLIKE ME, ABSOLUTELY.
THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING TO.
THERE’S NO PLAN IN PLACE SO I’M
JUST GOING TO BE THE SCAPEGOAT
FOR THE CITY.
>> Brian: IT SO HERE WE GO
AGAIN FACING A SECOND ROUND OF
SHUTDOWNS.
THE MAN THAT YOU JUST SAW, JUAN
DEMERITS JOINS US NOW.
THE NEWS IS ESPECIALLY
DISTRESSING FOR BUSINESS OWNERS
LIKE YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
>> WE WILL STAY OPEN AND
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
WE WILL NOT BE BULLIED OR LIVE
IN FEAR AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE ON.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THIS
STOP US.
>> Brian: WILL YOUR CUSTOMERS
COME?
>> WE ARE BOOKED SOLID, WE ARE
THE BUSIEST SHOP IN TOWN.
WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE AND EVEN OUT OF
THE STATE.
WE ARE BOOKED AND IT’S NOT
SLOWING DOWN.
>> Brian: JUAN, SINCE YOU WENT
BACK ONLINE AGAINST THE LAW AND
THEN THEY RELEASED YOU TO DO
THIS, HOW MANY OF YOUR CLIENTS
AND CUSTOMERS TESTED POSITIVE
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, NONE.
NO ONE HAS EVER COME IN AND TOLD
US, NONE OF MY BARBERS HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE, MY SELF HASN’T
TESTED POSITIVE AND NONE OF MY
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE.
THESE TESTS ARE JUST GOING TO
CONFUSE EVERYONE, ESPECIALLY FOR
THE FACT THAT THE TESTS ARE
PROVING THAT THE DEATH RATE IS
GOING DOWN AT A GREAT RATE.
THERE’S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON TO
KEEP SHUTTING DOWN OUR ECONOMY,
SHUTTING DOWN OUR STATE OR
SHUTTING DOWN >> Brian: THIS
IF CALIFORNIA HAD 2011 NEW CASES
COMING IN THE PAST WEEK.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT THEM TO
DO?
>> IF YOU TEST MORE THERE WILL
BE MORE POSITIVE CASES, THAT’S A
STATISTIC FACT.
NO ONE IS ARGUING THAT.
BUT IT’S NOT DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
HEALTH, IT HASN’T BEEN
DETRIMENTAL TO THE DEATH RATE.
WE HAVE LIVED WITH TB AND
WHOOPING COUGH AND FLU FOR OUR
ENTIRE LIVES.
THAT NEVER SHUT DOWN A NATION
BEFORE AND THERE IS NO REASON TO
SHUT IT DOWN NOW.
THE ONLY REASON THAT GAVIN
NEWSOM IS DOING THIS IS BECAUSE
HE ENJOYS THE POWER, AND HE WILL
CONTINUE TO FLEX IT AS MUCH AS
HE CAN.
>> Brian: HEY JUAN, HOW MUCH
DOES GAVIN NEWSOM GET PAID IF
THERE’S A SHUTDOWN?
I BELIEVE THE SAME AMOUNT.
HOW MUCH DO YOU GET PAID?
>> WE GET PAID NOTHING.
THERE’S NO UNEMPLOYMENT FOR US,
THERE’S NO PPP IN LINE FOR US.
ALL THESE BIG MAJOR CORPORATIONS
ARE GETTING PAID AND LITTLE
CORPORATIONS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES, THEY WANT US TO
BREAK OUR BACKS AND NOT GET PAID
AND STEP AWAY FROM WHAT WE DO.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO GOOD
LEADERSHIP AND EITHER OF THE
PARTIES INCLUDING THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I FEEL LIKE RIGHT NOW THE ONLY
ONE USING ANY TYPE OF COMMON
SENSE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
WHITE HOUSE STAFF AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR US HE’S NOT
AROUND HERE SO WE ARE GOING TO
STAY OPEN.
>> Brian: OVER THE LAST FIVE
MONTHS, I’VE HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE BETWEEN PAYING YOUR RENT
AND PAYING UTILITIES, BETWEEN
PAYING MORE EMPLOYEES, TAKING
CARE OF BUSINESS AND WORKER’S
COMP., YOU HAVE YOUR HANDS FULL
EVERY DAY.
ALL YOU WANT IS A CHANCE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
HOW DOES IT FEEL THAT SOMEONE IS
ROBBING YOU OF THAT CHANCE AND
TELLING YOU YOU ARE SELFISH FOR
FIGHTING TO MAKE A LIVING?
>> LISTEN.
I’M NOT GOING TO BE BULLIED BY
ANYONE INCLUDING
GOVERNOR NEWSOM, ALL OF OUR
SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN THAT
ARE UNWILLING TO MAKE A STAND ON
THIS.
I TELL THEM, I’M NOT ASKING FOR
A PENNY, I’M NOT ASKING FOR A
HANDOUT AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
CHARGE ON.
AND I’M NOT GOING TO BE BULLIED,
THAT’S NOT THE AMERICAN WAY.
>> Brian: I HEAR YOU, JUAN.
BEST OF LUCK, WE ARE GOING TO
TRACK YOU.
I KNOW YOU WILL STAY SAFE
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE NOT, AND